[Musique]
et c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus à la une ce soir la
somalie et organise enfance une élection
présidentielle maintes fois repoussé
elle aura lieu ce dimanche un second
temps indirecte ce sont les
parlementaires qui devront choisir le
nouveau chef d'état parmi les 39
candidats nous ferons un point sur les
enjeux de ce scrutin
on parlera aussi de mauvaise gouvernance
au niger un rapport de la cour des
comptes pointe du doigt de nombreuses
irrégularités dans la gestion de
l'argent public
une plainte a été déposée par plusieurs
associations
et puis à la fin de ce journal nous
retrouvons fatimata one qui suit pour
nous le femua il sera accompagné des
membres du groupe magic system et
surtout organisateurs du festival des
musiques urbaines
elle aurait dû avoir lieu il y a un an
et demi déjà à l'élection présidentielle
en somalie se tiendra finalement ce
dimanche l'organisation de l'élection
avait pris beaucoup de retard en raison
notamment de différends politiques et ce
ne sont pas les citoyens mais les
parlementaires qui sont appelés aux
urnes les précisions de laurent père
pêcheur
à quelques jours de l'élection une
myriade d'affiché de pancartes surplombe
les rues de mogadiscio en tout trente
neuf candidats sont en lice pour le
premier tour de la présidentielle un
record en somalie pays pourtant connu
pour son paysage politique morcelé
il y à un nombre élevé de candidats à la
présidence parce qu'il n'ya pas de parti
politique en somalie
comme il n'y a pas de partie l'élection
est ouverte à tout le monde
ouvre un candidat à sa réélection le
président sortant pharma jo fera
notamment face à deux autres anciens
chefs d'état hassan sheikh mohamud et
sharif cheikh ahmed le vainqueur sera
confronté à des défis de taille
l'insurrection djihadiste des shebab la
crise économique et une sécheresse
historique
mais l'élection devrait surtout mettre
fin à une crise politique qui dure
depuis plus d'un an
après la fin du mandat de pharma jo en
février 2021 les dirigeants n'étaient
pas parvenus à se mettre d'accord sur la
tenue d'un nouveau scrutin le processus
a été maintes fois repoussée en raison
notamment d'un bras de fer opposant le
président au premier ministre le nouveau
chef de l'état devra donc être capable
de rassembler la classe politique
somalienne
la plupart des élections en somalie ont
suscité l'espoir d'un changement et je
crois vraiment que ce scrutin parce
qu'il a pris si longtemps offre la
possibilité d'un nouveau départ si aucun
candidat n'obtient plus des deux tiers
des voix un deuxième est potentiellement
un troisième tour sont prévues pour les
départager
près de 100 millions d'euros en moins
pour les caisses de l'état nigérien
voilà ce que la mauvaise gestion des
deniers publics a coûté à niamey selon
un rapport de la cour des comptes trois
réseaux d'associations porté plainte à
la suite de la publication de ce
document le gouvernement a annoncé de
son côté limogeage de plusieurs cadres
comme nous l'expliquent notre
correspondant à alger rares
c'est un rapport qui rappelle
l'envergure de la tâche à
l'administration bazoum ce document de
plus de 300 pages rédigé par la cour des
comptes épingle la gestion de l'argent
public au niger entre 2013 et 2020 les
investigations menées pour ce rapport
porte sur l'attribution de marchés
publics sans réelle compétition les
divers sur facturation de prestations à
l'état nigérien mais aussi l'action de
plusieurs organismes à travers des
dépenses publiques qui ont effectué
justement ces dépenses sans aucune base
légale les dépenses publiques sont très
peu contrôlées au niger c'est ce que
conclut ce rapport et c'est ce qui a
aussi poussé plusieurs associations mais
aussi plusieurs réseaux 2g
anticorruption a porté plainte mercredi
au parquet de niamey elle appelle toutes
les pouvoirs publics à une action une
réponse rapide
aujourd'hui comme vous les gardez ces
diables pense à ça le fait que donner à
réalité du courage à ce qu'ils veulent
la réalité d'étonner les fentes public à
ceux qui veulent détourner les fonds
publics ceux qui veulent continuer à
corrompre et à pourrir notre marché
public saha réalité ça encore de la
valeur de ces deux noms de toutes les
façons margot l'épaule et aux partis
politiques où on est on est sauvés ou
aidés protéger entre guillemets par
certaines personnalités de ce pays rien
ne peut nous arriver nous avons tenté
plus tôt de contacter le ministère des
finances publiques pour une interview
mais pour l'instant sans succès le
gouvernement de son côté veut faire
valoir une politique anti corruption
active mohamed bazoum le président
nigérien a d'ailleurs récemment annoncé
qu une trentaine de hauts cadres de
l'état et est actuellement en prison
pour malversations ou détournement de
fonds publics et il resterait longtemps
peu de temps après cette annonce il y a
quelques semaines mahamadou zada le
ministre de la communication en exercice
à l'époque a à son tour été écroué il
est accusé entre 2013 et 2020 t1 d'avoir
détourné plus de 3 milliards de francs
cfa de deniers publics
la france promet son soutien à la guinée
pour un retour des civils au pouvoir ce
vendredi une délégation du ministère
français des affaires étrangères ainsi
que désormais s'est entretenu avec le
ministre guinéen du territoire et la
décentralisation
les échanges ont porté sur l'envoi
d'experts électoraux en guinée pour
l'organisation des élections dans le
pays je vous propose d'écouter maury
condé ministre guinéen de
l'administration du territoire et de la
décentralisation au micro de manic
d'équité
nous sommes dans une tradition et le cnt
adopté la résolution souvient 36 mois au
niveau du gouvernement nous avons de
l'obligation est d'aller
très vite j'ai rapidement et sur le
processus afin de pouvoir tenir ce délai
la france a déjà approuvé l'envoi et de
défaire les toiles pour appuyer le
glisser dans un territoire la
décentralisation mais également au
niveau de la francophonie et la france
est en train d'appuyer afin que la
francophonie aussi plus mobilisé des
experts dans ce sens
n'était le fugitif le plus recherché par
la justice pour son rôle dans le
génocide des tutsis en 1994 protêt une
piranha est en réalité décédée en 2006
au zimbabwe c'est ce qu'a annoncé l'onu
il commandait la très puissante garde
présidentielle au moment des massacres
pour la principale association des
rescapés du génocide à mort de protée
piranha est une perte pour la justice
au mali plusieurs centaines de personnes
se sont rassemblées ce vendredi à bamako
en soutien à l'armée aux militaires au
pouvoir ainsi qu'à la coopération
militaire avec les russes les drapeaux
russes ont d'ailleurs été brandie les
manifestants dénonçaient les sites des
sanctions de la cedeao toujours en
vigueur et les conséquences de ces
sanctions se font ressentir au delà des
frontières maliennes au sénégal par
exemple les exportations vers le mali
ont baissé de 60% en février à kédougou
de nombreux commerçants dépend des
échanges quotidiens avec le voisin
malien et les mandats au sein de
ratisser sarah sakho se sont rendus sur
place
le corridor dakar-bamako tourne au
ralenti le trafic de cette importante
axe commercial subi de plein fouet les
impacts de la fermeture des frontières
avec le mali mohamed est un transporteur
de marchandises cerveau lui habituels
ont chuté ces derniers mois nous sommes
en moldavie nous sommes fatigués de cet
embargo il ne nous arrange pas du tout
mais c'est nous les transporteurs qui en
souffrent le plus
avant on faisait deux à trois voyages
vers le mali par mois mais aujourd'hui
on fait au maximum
le gagnant les denrées alimentaires ne
sont pas concernées par les sanctions
économiques vers prix a toutefois flambé
en raison du renforcement des contrôles
aux frontières les commerçants
répercutent le temps et l'argent perdus
sur les produits à kédougou ville
frontalière du mali les populations se
plaignent de la cherté de la vie et
prédit on en demandait est ce que la
viande qui coûtait
après neuf ans est devenue maintenant
atteint kg nous importons l'avion du
mali la fermeture des frontières
beaucoup c'est pourquoi elle est devenue
chère à la chambre de commerce de
kédougou on suit cette situation de très
près cette agence inquiète des
conséquences néfastes de l'embargo le
mali est le premier partenaire
commercial donc du sénégal donc dans la
sous région donc nous ce qui nous
inquiète c'est vraiment la paix ce
vraiment donc des recettes donc au
niveau local mais c'est surtout que
c'est les perturbations dans
l'approvisionnement
et et ça si ça continue ça va entraîner
donc ici aussi renchérissement des prix
en mars dernier la cedeao avait demandé
aux militaires au pouvoir au mal et
l'organisation d'élections dans un délai
de 12 à 16 mois à faute d'accord
l'organisation avait décidé de maintenir
à ces sanctions contre le mari on ne
sait pas encore à ce jour quand
l'embargo sera levé d'ici là ce sont les
populations qui vont continuer de subir
les conséquences de la fermeture de la
frontière avec le mali
la direction abidjan qui vit au rythme
des concerts de la femua jusqu'à
dimanche le festival des musiques
urbaines a été créée il ya maintenant 14
ans par salif traoré membre du groupe
magic system notre envoyé spécial
fatimata one est sur place avec les
magic system qui doivent remonter sur
scène ce samedi après huit ans d'absence
regarder
demain soir les fan ça fait huit ans
qu'ils vous ont pas vu vous produire
eh ben comment vous avez ce que ça va
être un spectacle nouveau différent
comment vous allez laborde et là on les
applis de pendant huit ans du show de
magic system on a été un peu égoïste et
cette fois on a décidé de voter la casse
tête que commissaire où je le mets dans
la peau de l'artiste donc demain ça ne
les trouvailles c'est la folie nyon et
on va chanter et prier avec un enfant
parce que la frontière de magic system
ce sont deux places le façonnement de
concert donc on va se retrouver dans
communion de prière en tout cas vous
avez entendu il va y avoir une ambiance
incroyable exceptionnelle qui a attendu
ici je sais pas si vous entendez
derrière moi vous avez le groupe viva la
musica voilà c'est la rumba congolaise
qui nous entraîne n'est ce pas tout le
monde est extrêmement motivé les gens
vont arriver petit à petit sachez que le
femua ça dure toute la nuit c'est très
long les gens vont venir de partout
c'est un spectacle qui est gratuit qui
est ouvert à tous voilà et ça fait 14
ans que ça dure et c'est aussi un
spectacle sociale évidemment on l'a dit
répété sa petite année le focus est mis
sur la jeunesse et l'emploi des jeunes
donc c'est vraiment un spectacle et un
festival qui à la fois social et musical
donc très utile et en même temps les
gens se régale parce qu'il ya toujours
des têtes d'affiché incroyable d'un mois
et à viva la musica c'est le groupe
mythique de papa wemba qui se produit et
le spectacle est prévu pour durer une
bonne partie de la nuit et on entend
l'ambiance en des remous dans le mur le
spectacle la partie ça a démarré ce à
commencer par les rues mollien le coupé
décalé ce soir ya le zouglou ce soit
tous tes besoins dont tout est prévu
donc venez sur 7 sur ce et si l'on
suivait sur internet et voilà rendez
vous est pris c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique merci à vous pour votre
fidélité merci aux équipes en régie et à
l'édition belle soirée sur france 24
[Musique]